[Music]
well good evening at welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight you think house of cards
is a TV show sort of also kind of real
though it turns out today the FBI
brought charges against the former
director of security for the Senate
Intelligence Committee it was part of an
ongoing investigation of secret
information that has been leaked to the
press over the years the man in question
is called James wolf he was in charge of
handling information as it passed from
the executive branch to the Congress
wolf had access to huge amounts of
highly classified information
including intelligence documents now a
job like that requires unimpeachable
integrity wolf is accused of leaking
classified material to several reporters
and then lying about it to the FBI
and it gets weirder from there allegedly
wolf passed information to a college
student called Ally Watkins Watkins
later went on to become a reporter at
several media outlets including Politico
BuzzFeed and the New York Times wolf who
was in his 50s has admitted having a
relationship apparently with Watkins
that went on for three years
Watkins has denied that wolf was ever a
source for her stories but text messages
released today strongly suggest
otherwise here's one quote I always
tried to give you as much information so
you could get that scoop before anyone
else Wolfe wrote to Watkins I felt like
I was part of your excitement and was
always very supportive of your career
and the tenacity you exhibited to chase
down a good story it goes on like this
it's pretty sad and a little creepy I
felt like I was part of your excitement
you know you imagine these guys are
sinister it turns out they're mostly
this pathetic though they are kind of
sinister too actually the Russia hoax
would not exist it wouldn't astha size
to take over our entire government our
entire national conversation if corrupt
bureaucrats like this weren't misusing
their power which they are so it's hard
to feel too much sympathy for this wolf
guy on the other hand the feds once
again are prosecuting somebody whose
sole alleged crime is lying to the feds
it would be nice of our government went
after people for real crimes once in a
while might make you feel a little
better about the system the DOJ also
seized phone and email records from a
reporter in this case and apparently
broke into encrypted text exchanges
didn't know that was possible turns out
it is this all looks a lot like what the
Obama people used to do it was racing
then and it's worrisome now when the
government spies on American citizens it
is always a big deal
whether those citizens are New York
Times reporters or whether they are
Trump campaign staffers it doesn't
matter there had better be a very good
reason for spying on Americans the media
of course do not recognize this they
only care when it's someone who shares
their politics as far as they're
concerned conservatives deserve to be
wiretapped just because they're
conservative the press are partisan
buffoons who wouldn't know a principle
if it got in the shower with them but
the point remains dan bond Gina was a
former NYPD officer and Secret Service
agent and he joins us tonight dan if you
would since I need you follow this story
more carefully than anyone I know put
this in context for us how does this
wolf character fit into the larger story
well Tucker the name of Carter page was
was he was relatively anonymous in this
scheme Carter page had assisted the FBI
in a prior case where they locked up a
Russian spy in the Bureau yakov case but
the name was relatively unknown at that
point Wolf's the one who leaks the
existence of the name carter page well
if he said the name was there leaks the
name to ali watkins who then writes this
story the story is then this is where it
gets ugly tucker and this is why the
press has zero credibility in this at
all that story by Watkins is incited
repeatedly to advance the Pravda like
media propaganda story that Trump's
cooperating with the Russians because
Carter page now that they have the name
was a trump foreign policy advisor this
was used over and over again this is the
this circle of lies and deceit we see
and I agree with you your opening
statement spot on this is I am I I have
a libertarian spine and I don't care
who's in office I am always concerned
about the freedom of the press period
full stop but what I find absolutely
hypocritical is media Pravda like
phonies complaining now about government
overreach while you've been dead silent
on spying on the prosecution of Mike
Flynn
on all of this stuff give me a break you
forfeited your voice to talk a long time
ago spying but it wasn't spying remember
that when a paved government informant
gathered information secretly on three
separate Trump campaign officials and
sent it back to the government without
telling the Trump campaign that wasn't
spying that was just the FBI doing its
duty right you know it's a basic I
watched your interview which is a
classic by the way with a police state
or erics whoa well the congressman from
California who when he mentioned spying
you know he actually said something that
was true to you tucker and to be fair
he's not here to defend himself but he
said hey we only spy on the bad guys he
was right Trump was the enemy this is
the new liberal police state mindset
Trump is the enemy not the Chinese not
the Jew trade relationships with the
Chinese not the Russians the real enemy
was Donald Trump he was absolutely right
this is the new liberal mindset Trump is
the bad guy and you're right
as long as you're spying on
conservatives it's a-ok and we'll play
the euphemisms game now he was he was an
informant that's nonsense he was a spy
and everybody knows it we used to have
trials that helped us understand who was
the bad guy or not I mean people were
accused of things and then it went
before a jury or a judge and we knew for
certain but now the accusation is itself
considered proof of guilt when did that
happen
yes I'm glad you brought this up because
Tucker remember this is what frequently
gets lost in this Wolf's related to this
Carter page story remember Carter page
is the entry point for the signals
intelligence spying operation the
interception of the emails and texts
into the Trump team Tucker nobody to
this day has provided a scintilla of
evidence that there was probable cause
of the two things they needed a spy on
Carter page that he was acting as a
foreign agent or on behalf of a foreign
agent and secondly in violation of US
law nobody has shown that Carter page is
out doing cable interviews probably
tonight somewhere this is nonsense if
Carter page was guilty why hasn't Carter
page been charged I mean as you just
pointed out he his behavior was the
pretext for this entire story so doesn't
it tell you something
he's not even been incredibly accused of
upon the FBI the Department of Justice
Tucker worked it walked into a Florida
Intelligence Surveillance Court use the
Prada fective Lee the Star Chamber right
used to prosecute the worst among us
terrorists the worst savages on the
planet they bring Carter Paige in there
to spy on him and you're right there is
he's out walking around right now a
matter of fact the FBI is not
interviewing him I know of no controls
on his behavior at all it's free answer
is because there probably is no
indications of criminal behavior at all
and they desperately want that angle of
it to go away and once you talk to
Carter pages you may have you realize
how sad this whole thing is I mean
Carter page was never a Russian agent an
agent of anybody I'm not even sure he
does for a living I mean it's pathetic
dan thank you it's great to see you yes
sir